una deuda con el planeta arabia saudita
uno de los mayores productores de
petróleo del mundo anunció que pretende
alcanzar la neutralidad de carbono para
los complace en lanzar la iniciativa en
el ámbito energético que nos permitirá
reducir las emisiones de carbono en 278
millones de toneladas anuales
el reino buscará reducir sus emisiones
usando un enfoque llamado economía
circular del carbono que busca invertir
en tecnologías de captura y
almacenamiento de estas emisiones
principales causantes del efecto
invernadero
tenemos que la captura utilización y
almacenamiento de carbono son elementos
que desarrollan los ingredientes
necesarios para garantizar este esfuerzo
y mitigar las emisiones
pero el anuncio incluye el territorio
saudí y deja por fuera las inversiones
en petróleo y exportaciones a asia y
otras regiones esa economía busca
diversificar sus ingresos que dependen
de la exportación de petróleo y gas el
anuncio se da previo a la reunión de la
cob 26 donde se espera que los jefes de
estados del mundo y empresas asuman
mayores compromisos para reducir sus
emisiones y combatir el cambio climático